hello everybody welcome back to let's
play let's say bigger yeah
well that's one way to start an episode
all right oh come on I was thinking of
starting the game from the loading free
but that I just remembered where I was
so run run away have your eyes adjusted
yet yes they have Oh what no no what
okay
Oh what uh-huh what the hell what the
hell is this Oh what da hell what hang
on what what huh I'm so confused
I'm so confused
what ah crap I'll come on what a guy
somehow mysteriously I don't like
radical Larry okay anyway what I was
trying to say what what haha I need a
key card operate the door what door what
is you talk about
what is you talking bout huh well you do
anyway I actually read up on how to yeah
I died okay I'm going to start a new
game
mark wins yeah because I actually read
up on what you need to do to win it's
all about radical Larry idli enough you
need to get that code so you can um you
can get through the sewers or the
tunnels but he's always going to spawn a
town so what you need to do is you need
to get him out of the equation by
getting to this containment empty
containing
yes Baba so you need to get into his
zone then get out safely and then get to
his place safely again go on your merry
way and how poop mucking can safely in
and out it's totally possible to get out
of this place it is this has unending
and I'm gonna find that oh why do I have
so many of these black smudge on the
ground why so many of these dark tunnels
like this Hollis's please yes awesome oh
there is the machine why so many tunnels
like this I don't like those type of
tunnel oh ok alright so that's where I
can get another key card if I need it I
need to find some office hey hey hey I
thought a crap crap no you don't know
you don't your
not on my watch ah oh crap I'm in their
offices it let's have a staring contest
a no no blink crack all right that was a
bum seed but I know what I need to do
all right mark wins - I know what I need
to do I just have to get into a position
where I can do that if I can get the key
card again I know what to do and then
after that I'm good I'm like golden I
can do it you believe in me you know I
right
no sign of um yeah screen oh come on I
hate that anymore
all right come on
Brad italeri come on all right
oh yeah I'm good go go go
Oh get too close close close thank you
say thank you okay look okay I thought
it was in a different area
oh stop it stop it stop it
ah no clothing cook dango no crap oh
it's the Machine okay I just got to get
by him yeah buddy well yeah where yeah
where are you at
do leave left okay this game stress me
oh no it's a dead room come on
why do I keep getting these ah-ha what
oh come on crap I think I think I lost
again
oh no wait there was another way okay I
know where the machine is okay it's not
over yet not over yet it's not over yet
all right all right all right all right
doing good doing good again that's where
I need to be don't don't
where's that a lot of empty hallways
okay there's a maintenance tunnel okay I
got that I know where the machine is and
the maintenance tunnel okay okay
I'm officially screwed on this
playthrough okay I gotta get out of here
start a new one it's really I'm like you
know you play it enough and you start to
understand the game to a point where you
don't want to understand it anymore but
you understand the game and I understand
it
I understand it very myself I know how
to beat this game I don't like this game
I know how to beat it wasn't ready for
that
shut up [ __ ]
hi
scuse me fine kill me ah oh man okay
oh man I'm gonna head on I like generate
my own gah but yourself
oh god oh man I don't even know oh don't
oh I now know the name of this place's
name of this episode is worst scare of
my life don't all an office right at the
beginning this is a good place
give me a key give me give me a key card
yes level 200 if you ever plays game use
the maps ego yourself oh thank you he's
not even here oh I love it
oh okay he's in there see him here we go
oh I see you get at all like up ah
handled just straight up handle
my heart's still going like a hundred
beats per minute per hundred thousand
it's a lot I should wear our heart
monitors and put put up put a a heart
monitor up on the screen to show you
guys how fast my heart beats sometimes
are not because then you'd worry about
my health
some of the more medically inclined
people watching it'd be like that's not
a good thing
oh oh oh oh ah poop monkey never mind
okay
yes oh yes this is the one everybody use
go poop yourself oh it's amazing okay
put that in put that in and put that in
oh yeah flip flutters I said bladedge
I think me playing these games is
eventually just going to reduce my
lifespan by quite a few years okay
Oh got the gas Mac that does not reduce
running I can run forever with this is
on right look at that look at that Oh
baby yeah yeah everyone knows when I
have a good time I turn into Elvis yeah
yeah let me get some of that oh yeah oh
yeah man that's some good ass [ __ ] oh
yeah ah should I yeah I'll go ahead and
don't ruin my day man don't ruin my day
don't ruin my day one seven three don't
ruin my day I'm gonna make an old image
radio transceiver and then get out of
here
you know you know I read up on the ASAP
site this SCP is my favorite now there's
so much stuff to read there
oh yeah
it broke I broke it
whoops all right well that was that's
not good
anyway radio transceivers not essential
to beating the game all right
radical Larry stopper showed up huh
don't ask don't ask everybody okay wait
a minute
back here I need to go back oh don't
tell me there's no way to get there
there's got to be a way there's got to
be a way I know there's a way all right
but that's gotta wait until next time
gang okay I got the card I got the
ultimate map nav thing 106 what he's on
my trail radical Larry's gonna find me
eventually so in the next episode we'll
get moving so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
video that I've done and as always I'll
see you in the next video bye-bye